we're now
here for episode 2 after
18 months
first round episode we now are back with
sydney campos thank you so much i'm so
happy to be here with you
and gosh what a journey we were just
kind of recapping our
last meeting and how much has shifted
and we're just new people again
so hi again
yeah the last yeah hour of convo around
becoming such new
people in
our dances yet also recognizing
ourselves
as the one intelligence doing the dance
rather than being the person which has
become also
kind of interesting as well
like negating all the way up to
recognizing oneself as that very source
one intelligence and then including the
fact
that we are the person in that
dance welcome to my show yeah
playing it all thank you for being
characters in my play
exactly exactly uh
yeah the eternal script the eternal
stage
and the appearances of the form
that appears and disappears on that
eternal stage
things are very melty lately more than
usual more and more
and it's such an amazing moment
you know like i feel like we're really
coming to terms with our
our power as creators
in such beautiful ways our reality is so
malleable
and what are we here to create what do
we want to experience what do we want to
receive
and there's literally no limit to what's
possible
you know and we're all learning how to
show up
with this new sense of power and
creatorship and stepping into more
aligned relationships
with other people that have that same
ethos
that want to co-create in this very
empowered
abundant way and it feels so good
man that is yes this is such a critical
component is
that when you gain these
powers of recognizing yourself as
the one intelligence then you realize
that you live in this
this infinite possibility space and that
you at any point
can then manifest and create that
highest excitement trajectory towards a
divine
north star calling purpose and
then we step into that more and more and
more and more also from the place of
unlocking
the the core again of the
title of the episode embodied ascension
this is sydney's
name for the her knights of the round
table retreat that she's having
i love that that came through earlier i
was trying to describe it to you like
what are you doing in maui and i'm like
we're basically having this knights of
the round table like
wizard circle convergence of just the
most amazing
leaders and creators coming together to
collaborate and to really accelerate our
own individual and collective healing
to deepen in presence to unlock more of
our multi-dimensional
perceptions and gifts and
so just practice being you know
ourselves
around other very powerful beings
it's gonna be so much fun and it's about
embodied ascension you know which
this term kind of came to me last year
it came to me before but it really
anchored in as a retreat container last
year
and since then i've taken on so many
initiations
to learn really to learn to embody that
because we're really over the phase
right where we can just like talk about
stuff without embodying it
yeah it doesn't feel good or you see
someone talking about something and you
can tell they don't really get it and it
just feels uncomfortable to listen
because it doesn't feel true and yeah
and it's cool that we can even have
these future visions you know i love to
be with visionaries and we're pulling in
vision from the future we come from the
future we're bringing things in to land
into this physical reality
and sometimes it's like we see the
vision of what's possible but then wait
a minute how do i embody that first
before it can be made manifest before it
can be actualized
how do i actually embody the energy
whatever this this vision
wants to be you know and what does it
really mean how do i live it as an
example
of what that is you know and then
whatever we're creating has
there's so much more support and you
know magnetizing
the right people uh the resident beings
that are meant to be a part of
it because they can really feel what it
is
like through your example they can
really we don't have to explain so much
you know we can just embody the energy
of the invitation
and people are like i don't even i don't
even need to know anything i just feel
this i feel this resonance
i know i'm supposed to be a part of it
let's do it
this would be a good time for me to ask
you about
what this looks like for you
in the last couple of years of
understanding this more deeply
because for me as we talked about in the
last
hour before we started the program is
that the 18 months
has been a
a place of really going intellectual
first
and we've talked about this with frank
yang on the show several times
we then become more and more
experiential with it
and then it really becomes realized and
i think realized and embodied into your
present
being is that last
component and it's really kind of that
very
end of the integrative process
which never really ends it just always
deepens and so
i would be really curious to hear
over the patterns that you've analyzed
in the last couple of years with people
would you say that the process of
sort of going
upwards towards what you could say is
some sort of an absolute or highest or
infinity or nothingness or just
trying to anchor what the nature of
reality is trying to at least grasp
what that is which we already are and we
then sort of undergo a process of well
how do i
live that every day moment to moment in
every interaction with the breath with
my water
with sydney in this conversation with my
mom and dad brother sister co-workers
and how do i maintain that love and
light
and unity as i do that how does that
resonate
i just hear my ears like ringing
joey means there's a lot of like
spiritual support just like yay we're so
happy you're having this conversation
right now
um i hear practice we're all just
practicing
we're deconditioning ourselves from all
the stuff we've learned
along the way along this lifetime that
taught us to shut down
aspects of ourselves and feelings
really natural responses to life that
were coming up to direct us
in perfect alignment with our path with
our destiny with our purpose
and at certain points in the path we
were afraid
we were neglected we were shamed and we
just
shut things down and so we're just we're
unwinding we're unwinding at such an
accelerated pace it's so exciting we're
getting blasted
all of humanity we're getting blasted
with so much energy
from all around so much support so many
different
entities beings consciousness is
wanting to help us in this ascension
awakening
return to home return to presence
and we're receiving so much whether
you're aware of it or not those of us
who have been
doing energy work or meditation or
healing for a little bit
feel it and the energy has shifted you
know i've shared this with a lot of
friends it's like
you wake up and you feel like you've
been getting a massive download like all
night long
make up a little bit hungover feeling
you know and our bodies are just
changing so rapidly and our energy
systems are updating
so immensely to accommodate
this embodied ascension process which is
one in
you know it's about presence and body
ascension means
i'm not ascending intellectually to this
celestial heavenly realm outside of
earth
and like in some other place like i have
to i gotta go
ascend into the 10th dimension and it's
this very like linear feeling
climbing the staircase like
from point a to point z process
what i found in my experience and also
in supporting many others is
you know ascension now is about
going in it's like an in a d-sension
actually
feels like more true it's like
deconditioning
detaching becoming empty
to your point around like nothingness
being in the void
learning to be comfortable being
in the void being in space not having
identities not having attachments i'm
not i'm not there all the time i'm not
there yet
i'm maybe i have little glimpses of what
that feels like and sometimes it's scary
it's like oh my god i'm so used to
having
to being busy to having identities to
having people know me as certain things
and
and attach you know just used to
carrying around a lot of attachments
and what's it like to let all that go
and to actually be
a clear conduit for divinity source
god your true self whatever you want to
say
whatever you relate to and none of it's
wrong all of it's right
it doesn't matter you know how do we
empty ourselves out to let
something even more true even more
beautiful even more great
come through us and then we're just
watching it's like watching the show
like oh it's not even manifesting
anymore right like we're evolving out of
manifestation
manifestation presupposes this linear
like
well first i have to set my intention
and then i have to visualize and then i
have to meditate and then i have to do
this and all this stuff has to happen
and then i'm going to manifest the thing
that i want in like 10 years
and it's like no i don't know i feel
like we're able to actually do
things a little bit more efficiently now
and we focus on cleaning out the system
cleaning out the energy field clearing
distortions healing trauma
it should happen so efficiently now and
then it's like
what we're already really wired to
experience to create
are manifestations they're already
happening in our reality
we're simply observing them it's coming
through us very effortlessly
and we're watching it unfolds in
presence
there's no linear conditional you know
program
like i have to do all this and then it's
i'm present
i'm allowing i'm receiving i'm trusting
something greater is coming through me
energetically this is
architecting new aspects of my reality
before my eyes and i'm not doing
anything other than witnessing
watching allowing appreciating loving
taking care of myself but really being
this conduit
you know and attracting everything
it's like everything i need the
resources the collaborations the support
it's all already here there's nowhere
to go get to there's nothing else that
needs to be done
fixed one of my students the other day i
was in session with and she just said
the most beautiful reflection she's like
she's doing a lot of reprogramming about
how she was taught to run a coaching
business
coaching practice and she's like what i
really get about you we've been working
together for a few months and she's like
you're just holding presents there's
nothing wrong
you're not coming to the session
thinking there's something to fix
looking for the thing we need to resolve
and fix so that it feels like something
happened
so it feels like some resolution was
delivered
so it feels like you know you got the
whatever you paid for
like this is the old programming and
it's like how long were we conditioned
to look for something that's wrong to
fix
and maybe there's nothing wrong with it
there's nothing wrong and everything's
actually fine and how can you love and
accept yourself as you are and
it's you're already healed it's okay
there's nothing in the way of being
where you want to be
which is present with what's happening
now and enjoying your life
enjoying your body enjoying
everything as it is not wanting to
change or fix
anything at all and when we let go of
these
we have so much more energy we have like
so much more energy running through our
systems to like
just enjoy life to play to allow things
to be created through us
so much more creativity so much more
capacity
for love and intimacy
how's that land
so good so good so
hitting the tennis ball back it sounds
like
a lot of what's happening in our one
intelligence undergoing this lila this
divine play is that we
we have this secretion of
of self-awareness
yeah i made this video called infinite
secretion like a month
so so we secrete the self-awareness and
then
we over time become less and less
deluded and intoxicated by maya
and the illusion the intoxication and we
become more and more
aware to divinity to god to source to
the love light unity
wisdom presence that you're talking
about and so the whole process in a
sense
is a like you said practicing
spirituality is really realigning
ourselves
to the one heart which is naturally
unfolding
that process naturally unfolding and the
realigning to the one heart is really
the deconditioning the deprogramming
the unwinding of the contracted energies
and becoming more and more comfortable
with the emptiness more and more
comfortable with the void becoming a
more and more clear conduit for divinity
god's source and holding that presence
with us
to where everything that we become a
part of
is seeing it all as the divine play
of love light and surrendering to
the unfolding whether or not like you
said sometimes we're coming in
so aggressively
in a place of i must change this
situation
because there's needs to be realigning
rather than just
inhaling exhaling and just being with
the beauty of the play as it is and
knowing trusting surrendering to the
fact that it's going to
divinely unfold to that realigning that
we've been talking about
yeah what if everything's fine what if
there's nothing to worry about
what if there's nothing to fix
you know we're collectively learning to
be a calm
to be at ease it's a nervous system
shift
you know we've been undergoing
especially last year and
just like stay at home quarantine like
rebuild your nervous system be with
yourself be quiet like stop being so
busy and just moving on autopilot
through your life
as it's passing you by
and this is very confronting for most
people i would imagine
some of us were like yay retreat time
like
yes you know um
it's just it feels so simple to me
sometimes i mean i'm i'm
constantly in deep practice my whole
life i think at a certain point you
realize
like my whole life is spiritual practice
like every moment is a spiritual
practice like how am i responding
in an integrity with authenticity
or is some other program running some
other
some survival strategy running
and that doesn't feel good and what do i
do instead how do i
show up as me what does that feel like
i'm just constantly practicing you know
that's what this whole thing is this
life
it's just practicing being present being
ourselves
it's really simple but it we're each
such complex
amazing beings you know we each have
really unique well they're actually not
so unique we have like universal traumas
that are expressed in very unique ways
but we all kind of got the same stuff
going on at
some level you know that we're not so
different
we have a lot more in common than we're
taught to believe you know
and we're so resilient and
we love i don't know i just find through
like
my experience like it
simplicity feels so good it's like at
the end of the day i wonder how many of
us
it's like we're just little babies it
feels like we just want to be
like held bad really good food
have really good rest nap time and play
and like hang out with our friends and
you know enjoy
i really feel like it's kind of that
simple and a lot of the healing
experiences i like to create and
co-create and share with others whether
they be
entrepreneur business incubators or
trainings of
you know healing and intuitive
facilitation
or building a new company
you know it's like i just like bringing
that sense of simplicity and also
humility to the table
and and also it's very helpful in seeing
each other and that for me it's helpful
to see other people in that light
especially if someone's triggering or
acting aggressively
or you know just acting in a way that
doesn't feel good it's like oh
i can see that person's inner child
that's just not
taken care of and didn't get what they
needed and
how can i just be a supportive loving
presence for them right now because
they'll figure it out
they wouldn't be on earth otherwise
right now if they weren't at some level
willing to do the work
so every single one of those programming
slash
conditionings slash layers of the
onion
layers of the secretion
[Laughter]
that those
are what we are divinely
here to undergo awakening to
healing and integrating and transcending
that that's the entirety of this process
is learning how to love
the one intelligence learning how to
love itself
through the illusion of separation
[Music]
yeah we're just here to enjoy the whole
thing it's not it's just funny i used to
make such a big deal out of everything
like
living your purpose and i have to make
this huge impact on humanity and help
everyone ascend and like
be this like spokesperson and for
ascension and like you know
it's like yeah
i'm just gonna do what i want
and be around people that feel good
where there's not so much translation
needed
and i'm gonna go to the fields the
platforms the portals that feel good
i'm not gonna go show up in places where
i feel like my energy needs to be
diminished
or translated in a way that you know
other people need
can understand like pandering to some
kind of like lower
vibration or something it doesn't feel
authentic
so yeah it's a really interesting time i
loved how our earlier conversation we
talked a lot about discernment
and a key part of the embodiment and
ascension process is
discernment it's like being selective
about how you share your energy and with
whom you associate with
like energy is our most valuable
time is also you know of high value
but it's like where are you spending
where are you sharing your energy and
like how are you valuing yourself
in a way that you know like you're
selective about
your resonance that you choose to attune
with
you know and what is it like to only
connect in relationships that feel
really balanced
that feel nourishing that feel good and
not
making sacrifices to be around people
that are draining or
i mean just draining and we get to be
very
honest about these things now especially
as
leaders you know all of us are leaders
in different capacities
and we get to be really responsible with
how we manage our energy and how we are
sharing our energy
and we can't allow ourselves to be
drained
we each have a really awesome mission to
be on you know and our full energy is
required
to show up
i love you're experiencing that in your
path and you're like you're getting that
and you're having this experience of
kind of up leveling your
resonance and just feeling everything
that unlocks when you're like i'm not
gonna be around this energy anymore and
i'm only gonna focus on
collaborators that like they lift me up
and they're elevating and they're
inspiring and they're powerful and
they're high integrity and they're
awesome and i just love being around
them and then so much
unlocks in you you're like wait a minute
i'm like so much more effective and i'm
having all these ideas
and i feel so supported and there's so
much more abundance
you know
what it's all about
so well said yes yes
yes and the in the beautiful thing is
that
then those that
maybe you quote separated from
in order to surround yourself with more
of what feels really good on your
nervous system
in architecting abundance that they
themselves are the one intelligence
still of course
that will eventually in this divine
unfolding
end up undergoing a similar process
themselves where they begin to more and
more surround themselves with those that
feel good on their nervous systems
and ascend in that embodied process
together
and so it's yeah
so it's yeah what what's what feels like
is in your highest excitement that
you felt like you needed to
leave what wasn't in your highest
excitement is literally
about to show up for them as a choice in
their trajectory
and it's just repeating that same
process
for more and more souls so
yeah yeah it's really cool it happens
when we make choices
that are really clear for us and then we
like detach from people
that are not in that choice and we set
them free
maybe they were latching on to us in
some way or we were playing some
unconscious like codependency thing with
them
and then we're like i'm going to choose
integrity or this feels more authentic
now i'm going to let that go
new timeline and we like set all these
people free
to go see what's more true for them
you know and then more resonance like
you said so beautifully like
more resonance can form more unified
fields can form
and and it's like we're all free to
refine
even more like oh i'm making more
choices that feel good now i'm even more
clearly attuned
to what really works for me what's
really aligned
and you become more refined in your
ability to sense
from like millions of miles away what is
good for me and what is not and you're
just even more aligned on the path more
aligned on the path
and then more resonant connections
opportunities resources can just
find you because your frequency is so
clear there's no
interference there's no like well i
don't know maybe i'll still do this or
maybe
you're just clear and then all the
things that are meant to be with you
that are in
a match resonant match can just
that's magnetism
[Music]
and it's so much easier i'm finding it's
easier
you know this is something i used to
teach about like years ago i did some
course
called like mastering magnetism and and
had a really great capacity to like
intellectually kind of like
i felt kind of like i want to use the
term like intellectual masturbation like
where you can talk and it's like turns
you on because you just know the
concepts like
magnetism and like the first three
chakras and like unlocking your power
and
unleashing your genius and all these
buzzwords
and saying like activation every other
you know every other word and i was like
what are you talking about
and and that helped people and it was
cool but it also wasn't very embodied it
was like talking about
something and then talking about it in a
way that
maybe if i talk about this more and
other people are understanding it i'll
like
believe it as possible for myself and
um yeah just really interesting to be
getting more feeling it seeing it happen
like oh like this is magnetism
oh cause i cleaned up like all that
stuff that didn't work
i let go all those people i stopped
doing all the stuff i don't really like
wow there's like all these cool new
opportunities and potentials
arising in my consciousness showing up
in my reality things are feeling
really synchronistic like more than ever
wow this is feeling really fun i think
this is how it's supposed to be
oh my gosh it happened again it happened
again this is real
all that stuff we were talking about
it's it's really happening
and then you kind of stop talking about
it because you're just enjoying it this
is so cool
i wish everybody was experiencing this
wow that so plays into
the realization
of i am not
a person but i
am having a person
experience and
that
when that flip happens
which is in many ways the process of
awakening slash enlightenment
what happens is that
everything that sydney's describing with
the very spiritual way of seeing
the one intelligence as mastering
magnetism
it ends up coming
alive more and more lucidly
your presence and experience and when
that happens
then we even
fall silent because we're like wow
we're architecting with those that the
nerve the feel great on the nervous
system
we're seeing it every single day
happening
this magnetism in so many beautiful ways
and then those that come naturally
seeking to heal their confusion we serve
in pure service
and so yeah that's
super resonant super resonant
because it does start this way it starts
up here
i remember 18 months ago during
our interview and acro
around that span of months of time
period there was such a
you know the amount of times that you
have to look up
the word yoga meaning union in sanskrit
union you know with a god with absolute
what is what is mysticism union with god
absolutely what does this mean you know
um and you like look it up like i was
looking it up you know like dozens of
times trying to refine
my intellectual understanding and then
over time it becomes more
and more experiential it becomes more
and more
embodied and truly realized in the last
couple of months especially
and that's really what's meant by satori
and awakening and enlightenment when it
becomes embodied when it becomes
realized that this is one intelligence
at play with itself
through this illusory veilless veil
and that and that's simply
recognizing that this is already an
announcement of freedom
most simply put this as ineffable
perfection
already always free
and you are the absolute right here
right now
and you get to express yourself like a
firework
and and be
in divine pure
service to that one intelligence
is the coolest thing
that we could be doing with ourselves is
this divine play
that's why i'm here yeah i love that
thank you
yeah and i think we're all here to just
remember that we're like little kids
again that just is coming up so strong
in this conversation
like just because i know this this
platform communicates with
a lot of really high level leaders and
teeth and entrepreneurs and people that
are
you know making a big impact in a lot of
you know
very worldly fields and technology and
science and business and
investing and all kinds of things and
i'm just kind of seeing this image of
like all the like the like personality
suits
that we take on when we're like in these
corporate structures and companies and
ceos and
but underneath all of those costumes is
just like
this really beautiful divine innocence
child
and enlightenment to me is like becoming
the child again
being returning to our divine blueprint
who were we before any conditioning got
superimposed
on this body on this consciousness like
who is that authentic being who's that
authentic presence that knows
and embodies trust completely
that knows no such thing as fear
that is pure love that's pure
presence that has no conception of time
that's just listening to feelings and
intuitive knowing and just
acting immediately it's pure expression
no filter no editing
no care no worry it's like who's that
and that's what we're all invited to
explore
and it really requires us to give
ourselves permission
invites us to give permission to
ourselves
so just like wow like let go of all the
stuff that we've been holding up like
these
these ideas that have been installed for
so long in some cases like
you have to have it all figured out and
to be a powerful leader you need to be
perfect
and you need to be strong and show no
emotion and be like this
infinite generator machine that's just
like always working and
like have everything you just know
everything already
and it's like that never really felt
true but somehow we have these standards
that were said at some point and
you know let's just take
take a nice big break give ourselves a
break
coming back to
the very playground that
we adored so much
um and coming to that playground
as the adult without its conditioning
so coming to the playground as the adult
with no conditioning in pure service to
others
recognizing itself as that one
intelligence
and now we can really play
yeah and now we can like have an amazing
time it's like a friend of mine
always calls you welcome to earth
welcome to earth the greatest party
in all the universe with like the most
extraordinary amazing intelligent
genius beings from all across the
multiverse not even just singular
universe we're talking about
multiple universes our mind can't even
fully understand that the vastness the
magnitude
that we come from and we're all we all
came here
to like have this amazing experience and
it always does feel like a party all my
dreams are always like that you know
they're very lucid and it always feels
like
we're at a big party or i'm getting an
invitation to a party
that's frequently how my spirit guides
are also always like communicating
they're like having a big party and
i find that's a really helpful reference
like
how can your life feel more how can our
lives feel more
like our own ideal party or or
i don't know maybe it's even like a
playground i love that analogy
playground laboratory
like fun we're here to have fun
we're here to enjoy we really are
we're the only ones that don't let
ourselves really i think you know don't
let ourselves
have fun and enjoy the experience
yeah the laboratory the playground
the very alchemical vortex
dropping its
layers of egoic conditioning
and realigning itself to
purely serving itself
through serving others serving itself
through serving
others rather than serving
the individuated costume
out of the lack belief of an onion layer
of feeling unsafe or something happening
in trauma or childhood
and that not being healed and integrated
and transcended
yeah that's that's a really good way to
look at it is how do you want to show up
on the playground
i'm kind of seeing this really specific
image of like earth
as like a gym like we're all in a gym
and we're all like working out
but we're all in kind of different
stations of the gym like some people are
like bench pressing and they
need like a guide to help them like
bench press 500 pounds some people
are like i'm like a lighter machine some
people are just taking a jog because
it's fun and it's like leisurely
someone's even just like power walk i'm
like power walking on the treadmill
like a meditation walk and then actually
no i'm in the sauna part of the gym
i'm like in the spa part where you like
just go in the steam room and just
relaxing
you know but that image comes through
somehow very strongly right now just as
a fun analogy for like
earth at this time like learning to
embody
all of these ascension energies through
our systems
and we're all at different stages in the
journey
of our integration and and we're all at
different stages in the healing process
and so we're all at kind of these
different stations of the gym
some people might have like a certain
target goal of like weight loss or
building more strength you know we'll
have different goals and intentions and
reasons why we're there
but we're all in the gym to take care of
ourselves
to to improve to expand and we're all
kind of on a team
you know i really like that i like that
image
is that fun yeah
the the playground
being thought of as the gym
and are we at the gym
to pump the big weight
so that other people at the gym can
validate our strength or
that's so good or or are we just
hanging out at the gym
in the sauna just
because it's the unique way
that we feel called to vibe and
relax and be just like the flower
effortlessly blossoms towards the sun
the mind when it's quiet when there's
no mind when you penetrate the illusion
of separation and the mind quiets
and you get to know mind you feel the
nothingness and
infinitude blossoming like a flower
towards the sun and you become that
rather than being the toiling
mind creating suffering and malevolence
check out this 400 pound bench press
look at everyone looking at me
oh my gosh the other part though so
some of us are trainers in the gym
though because we've been in the gym for
a long time
many lifetimes and we can train
we can help train people and there's
like some coach there's like some
nutrition coaches like
there's some people that are guides that
are helping
and then sometimes we take breaks and go
to the sauna or like get a massage
you know but it's like everyone has a
role and but it's all in this
team orientation and
i love that i love i love how many
different lenses through which we can
kind of orient to this whole theater
game that we're in
yeah i love the gym lens that was a
really good one
yeah the plate that's all
we agree on that it's trips me out
sometimes to be so cognizant of it like
consciousness observing itself being
conscious and like living and being in
this body
and and even when we first reconnected
after a while you're like it's so nice
to meet like your
sydney costume again like
getting to know this costume again
because we're such different
costumes now they've changed and
yeah it's so fun to to play in this way
when you really become aware of
perception
itself you become aware that
the costume
that sydney is wearing is the same
seer as this costume
and then you recognize that that is that
one god
self in that
taking on the beautiful form of the
sydney and atlas costumes and these
eight billion
costumes and that when you get to that
understanding when you become really
aware of perception really aware of the
seer really aware of awareness
it makes it so you can't actually commit
malevolence
because you know you'd be hurting
yourself it doesn't make sense
so the utility of spiritual awakening of
realignment to the one intelligence is
the eradication of suffering the
maximizing of our potential
and making it so that the playground is
filled with
love and wisdom and peace and bliss and
unity and prosperity and abundance
the gym the theater
video game yeah yeah i just
gosh it goes so deep it's like
the infinite well you know
yeah that's the answer connect to self
connect to god through yourself connect
to god through your heart
ascension is an inside job know thyself
love thyself accept thyself forgive
thyself and exactly
you see yourself in everything and all
suddenly like littering becomes like
committing
a painful act to oneself because you're
even connected connected to earth it's
like earth is me
who are we this is this is a whole
family situation we have here
and integrity becomes
the key to everything it's like
integrity
integration unity is a part of that
right it's like i'm integrated with
everything and all it's all me
and so how do you show up when you know
when you feel that and you know that to
be true
all your decisions are informed from
this place of union of unity union with
life
like anything that i choose or decide
upon is going to have ramifications
that affect me even if it seems like
it's a decision
affecting others it's you know and and
our whole world just becomes a
completely different story
when more of us are you know
are embodying this way of being and it
doesn't need to be everybody
it's like we're all in such different
trajectories i feel like there's
simultaneous like
experiences of earth happening and each
of our realities like we're each and
completely different
experiences it's a miracle we can
communicate
i think i feel this frequently like how
are we even able to communicate
when atlas your reality your experience
your path
is completely unique from mine like we
have completely different orientations
to reality
to what it feels like to be in a body to
running it to what it feels like to run
energy to what it feels like to connect
to our intuition i mean there's so much
input
it's a miracle we're able to like have a
coherent conversation that actually like
you know makes points and things is
clear
and it but yet we are and it's it's
amazing and then we're consciously
observing and acknowledging the miracle
of this
wow how amazing what an incredible
exchange
and we're like telepathically
communicating beyond the words that are
spoken and things are happening in our
bodies and
energy is unlocking and we can feel the
collective consciousness
those who are ready to receive these
frequencies receiving them and they're
activating and unlocking and
even outside of this moment transcending
time
peop someone watching this now moment
from two weeks later
having that activation we can feel them
opening their heart
opening to receive more and transmit in
a different way and
you know talk about dissolving you know
but it doesn't take
what i'm always reminded of is like like
the for the ascension
right it's already planned it's already
like perfect
a lot of us have already gone through it
you know and we just came back this
incarnation to
experience ascension where we don't
leave the body you know we're here to to
go
deeply into the body and to feel the
full ascension of our
light
and then to like experience physical
reality how we are creating
how we are radiating from this place
it's a whole new it's a big dimensional
shift we're making on earth through this
experience
huge dimensional shift consciousness
shift and
the thing is what's so cool about energy
and this is scientifically backed by the
way like you know
it just takes like a small percentage of
humanity
to be anchoring these higher frequencies
to be embodying these energies to be
integrating these through our systems
to be meditating to be taking care of
ourselves to be acting with integrity
to be feeling unity
and it it just that little percentage
point zero one percent of humanity
aligning with with that way of being we
rip the loud and impact everyone else
and all the other energies we want to
attune with the higher frequency light
light seeks light light is attracted to
more light
you know we're just putting more and
more light together but it just is like
it's not even a critical mass it's just
like
and i think there's like numerous
studies you know like the
monks meditating and i think one example
actually cite and
something i'm writing is you know a
group of tibetan monks meditating in
baltimore which is known for having a
really high crime rate
and these monks meditated for a few days
and the crime rate dropped significantly
by like a huge percentage amount
and because their higher consciousness
had this impact of radiating through the
collective
and probably infusing more unity you
know and love within everybody around
and whether they're aware of it or not
they're receiving
that download and that's
impacting their decisions and aggression
or violence right
so i just love i love to acknowledge
that because sometimes people feel like
especially
around the ascension pioneering path and
they've been proofing forever and
they've
like self-sacrificing and especially if
they're in that energy
and they're like are we even doing
anything is any is this thing on is
anything happening like is the world
changing it still seems really weird
when i look at the news like it's
bizarre
is anything changing and it is it's
really
like so much has changed and is changing
and
and it's working you know like it's
working in everything that you do my
ears are really
thin extensively you know everything
that we do matters
every choice that we make matters every
movement with more integrity
really matters now more than ever and it
is impacting
such a deep level we may never know we
may never see
no one may ever give us credibility for
it's
beyond that some of us are just here to
like anchor in certain energies and
forget it
and most people will never even
understand or see that
not something we'll be paid for as a job
like it's you know it's like a spiritual
assignment
and we're just here to broadcast energy
this is a big part of my path i'm here
on maui i'm anchoring in certain
frequencies on certain grid lines
just through meditating and doing yoga
and doing my spiritual practice and
that's like the main focus of
of my life that's what it feels like
everything else is kind of like fun and
you know cool i'm creating all these
companies and writing and whatever but
the
foundation is receive higher dimensional
energies that are not so available on
earth yet because my system can
can receive this energy and anchor it
into the planet
and anchor it into my field so that just
in my field i'm broadcasting it through
the collective grid
so that others who are awakening to
these kinds of attunements
abilities remembrances and just receive
it
it doesn't matter if they know it comes
from me it's not about that we're
we're one so that's where the you know
we all come back
to that that oneness and unity
transcendent of needing credit or
needing to be known it's like
just sharing sharing from this overflow
of energy that we're receiving
that makes sense i don't know where that
came from
[Music]
yeah such a good way to
rap on that musical note because
it summarizes uh sri aurobindo and the
mother mira alfasa have a quote
as well that you never do yoga
for just yourself you always do it for
everyone
even unconsciously you're doing it for
everyone
so your union with clearing out
your conditioning and becoming a more
pure conduit for
divinity source god
that entire process is butterfly
effecting out
and positively harmonically
creating the embodied ascensionary
dynamics
that enable us to shift into alignment
with that one intelligence so
right now we're very confused
through the illusion of separation
which is the whole point of this game
and
the whole point of the game is to awaken
through that
illusion and to become better and better
stewards of the one intelligence
endlessly expressing itself yay
i like how you said ascensionary
it reminds me of i just told you like
whenever anybody says essential
essentially i always want to be like
essentially
like and then insert anything
essentially essentially that brings us
to a great close moment
[Laughter]
perfect sydney's got her visionary souls
podcast she's got
her awesome youtube channel with great
content she's got
her instagram page all those are linked
in the bio below she's got an awesome
retreat coming up with the knights of
the round table called embodied
ascension in maui in
june you can check out those links in
the bio below go and check those out
everyone we
adore you infinitely thank you for
tuning in thank you thank you love you
all
wow yeah we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode on embodied ascension where
you're at in the process sydney or i can
come in and hit the ball back so let us
know how you feel and where you're at
and
if the video brought you value give it a
like it helps the algorithm subscribe if
you haven't shared the video with other
people that you feel like this would
resonate with
and that is all
we do
[Laughter]
okay cool thanks everyone thanks sydney
all right i'm gonna end the broadcast
we'll stick in the studio okay
excellent bye bye five
five five five maybe oh
five five i'm like are you gonna wait
for five five